and over at the strat they're gonna ring
in 2021 in a very unique way
john our hector mejia is there live now
with what's going on tonight at midnight
hey hector happy new year's eve
hey there happy new year's eve we are on
floor 109
feels like we're freezing to death but
it's worth it because the view from up
here
the valley is beautiful and we can see
some early morning hours behind those
thick clouds right now on the morning of
new year's eve a beautiful sight this
morning
and you know what tonight without
fireworks on the las vegas strip the
strat is trying to do something
differently
what they're doing is a local will
actually jump from sky jump at the
stroke of midnight
they haven't been able to do that before
because of the fireworks and joining us
live we have stephen thayer who is vp
and general manager here at the strat to
explain
what's that all about good morning good
morning how are you doing great
uh so yeah with so many takeaways in
2020 you know fireworks big gatherings
big parties so we really had to think
about different ways to do things
uh this year so one of those great
opportunities we had that's an add-on is
this
jump from our sky jump attraction so
we're really excited
we did a social media event that anyone
was allowed to
enter and uh we picked a winner and
happened to be a local las vegas guy
and uh excited to have him jump at
midnight so the lucky winner by the name
of rhymes
reinsmith who will be wearing uh
something that kind of looks like the
crystal ball in new york city
we uh look that was the the premise of
the idea what more iconic of new year's
eve is the dropping of the ball
we figured we could emulate that here at
our iconic tower
and so yeah we had to get extra sequins
extra lights
this thing is is brighter than you could
imagine you can see from miles away
you can so we're excited it really looks
like a ball dropping but it's a person
there
so you mentioned a lot is different this
year including the operation so you guys
are taking
safety precautions throughout the day
yeah of course we
we will always have we have safety
precautions every day here at stratton
in las vegas and
new year's eve is no different we're
going to make sure that
uh capacity limits are held on to and
that
people are socially distanced wearing
masks and doing the right things
steven thank you for having us we'll be
back in less than half an hour to talk a
bit more about the festivities
for now reporting live from floor 109 at
the strat hector mejia
8 news now back to everyone